what did you learn about yourself and
about what you want out of life and out
of a future partner following your
breakup with Noah you know I I think it
was more so I just wanted a better
relationship with myself after
that I read something that you wanted to
maybe get into acting or music is that
still something that you are interested
in doing yeah so I've been you know ever
my mind said now is like if I'm going to
do something just like go for it like I
always tell people I'm like I learned
the best just throw me in with the shark
like that's how I learn and so as far as
acting yeah I spent all of uh 2019
studying I wanted to put time and energy
into that so um you know people wouldn't
feel like I just entered it you know
thinking
that you know like I like no I wanted I
want to understand the craft from an
artistic perspectives this year was
actually supposed to be acting for me
like I was pilot season was happening um
early this time last year or early this
year and things were going really well
my first TV show and then I also booked
my first film and I was like oh my God
like it's going to happen I'm so excited
because acting for me is super spiritual
as well like I'm able to either get
farther away from myself or closer to
myself depending on how I want to
utilize the character we were filming in
um Oklahoma City and then Corona hit so
everything's stopped and I was just like
no I was like why like I don't
understand like I was so excited and I
really felt like things were moving but
because of this pause I was able to
create future Prosperity I was able to
create Warriors um I was able to focus
on music as well which is what you're
talking about that's like know I've been
a poet for the last two years like
secretly oh my
God I didn't realize that so much of
poetry is music my musicality has always
been um very specific and and I just
music has been a part of my life for as
long as I can remember but I never had
enough you know belief in myself to go
down that
direction but I you know once Co hit I
was like this is an opportunity for me
to do this I'm going to take this as
like a lesson and so I went super super
deep into that wrote about 20 songs in
two weeks which was like crazy oh my God
what were you writing about or what are
you writing about and when came we hear
it yeah um I mean we're
releasing we're probably going to be
releasing like a song every month
depending on um it's there's really a
combination about everything I have this
one song that I think people really like
and it talks
about how this generation um we we're we
want love and yet we're so scared to
commit to that real unconditional love
and so it's like it's it's not so much a
love song it's it's about a generational
fear of intimacy and yet desire of being
seen so it's like an interesting kind of
like you can't want this
without meaning without being okay with
being that vulnerable to um give it to
someone else there's it's really about
everything it's kind of like my poetry
so like you know there's a one that's
more I I'm more of like a satad song
kind of a person but but like it's it's
a lot of things but there's a song about
it's called No fairy tale which has a
lot of uh not not so much I don't want
to say go as far as to say suicide but
it's definitely about depression and
feeling like you're fo Fool's Gold when
everyone thinks you're gold and like
that kind of a conversation my poetry is
a really interesting place for me to go
to because it kind of shows me where I
was emotionally um like a year ago or
you know six months ago and so what I do
is like I just pull from that poetry and
that subject and then I just create from
there I'm like it's my therapy so I hope
it's your therapy too yeah kind is it is
it would you say pop music in a way or
would you say it's more
like or so I definitely do acoustic
songs but now you know it's I'm so new
in this space that I'm just figuring out
where my sound is and stuff so we're
going towards more of like an R&B trap
which is like very interesting but it's
my favorite genre
sexy and empowering but then it has this
nice like um very Progressive like trap
base that I'm obsessed with so it's
either going to be like acoustic
beautiful or like trap and sexy and cool
so it's just super fun because there's
no root you know you mentioned um sort
of going back to a place where you were
like six months ago a year ago and how
writing and and poetry kind of I'm
assuming helped you out of those times
was that the time when you were going
through a breakup with a certain
someone ah the relationship
conversation um well yes there was you
know I always used the relationships as
in my life as a great way to learn
deeper about myself so that definitely
had something to do with it but then in
return I got to see like my relationship
with the Earth my relationship with my
friends and family and so I've written
about all of it kind of because I think
the relationships in our lives are our
biggest teachers because they literally
are our closest Reflections to each
other so we can be like how how do I
need to grow how do I need to evolve
what did this show me in myself because
no relationship is a failure it's it's a
lesson nor a blessing and so taking it
one or the other and just evolving from
there but like I'm g walk to the light
so you can come with
me no I love that though um what did you
learn about yourself and about what you
want out of life and out of a future
partner following your breakup with Noah
you know I I think it was more so I just
wanted a better relationship with myself
after that that was definitely the
conversation I had was just like okay
how can I now treat myself better how
can I you know I think a lot of people
when a breakup happens we um think it's
our fault we think we could have done
better we could have done this and for
me it was more so like okay like the
universe wants me to focus on myself and
like I can totally do that I can it's
it's not easy you know self self- Lov
and self-healing is not the funnest
thing ever but it was just it was
showing me like where I needed to evolve
and so that's how I took it um and
that's literally why I was like the
relationship with Earth is slightly more
important I think anytime anyone goes
through um an experience whether it be
like heartbreak or the loss of like a
friendship even whatever it is I think
it's nice when you can like Channel it
into into to positivity so exactly it's
fuel it's amazing Fuel and like everyone
that I know always gets excited for
something like that they're like oh like
you're GNA have so much inspiration
after this because it's just it breaks
you open like heartbreak just breaks you
open and is like here's your soul and
like create with it and so that's
exactly what happens for now are you
kind of focusing on your on yourself
like are you dating in quarantine do you
know what you want out of somebody or is
it just like Alexis time I think it's
it's Alexis time I'm focusing on you
know my companies are my babies right
now and so like that's you know I'm 23
so I'm just going to focus on building
the companies around me and make sure
that they're self- sustaining make sure
that they're doing their part in helping
this world and um being a guide for
girls who want to follow down this path
as well so um the relationship with
Earth and the relationship with um my
company are my most important right now
what do you see next for you in terms of
the Alexis Ren brand like what does the
next five years look
like that's big question
Katie um well you know hopefully I
fature prosperity to be um a huge brand
in that space and really helping girls
you know make these micro changes to
make macro changes um I love speaking
speaking is like become one of my new
passion so performing is really special
to me so I hope that you know the right
roles come into play in the next five
years as far as acting and I can really
like utilize I'm I'm such an emotional
person you know I'm like might as well
put those emotions somewhere and so
that's why acting was so great I was
like yes like Yay like I get to cry on
cam you know whatever like it is I'm
just like this is perfect and evolve um
to be you know to grow as as a better
person
um and then hopefully singing I just
singing I for me is like my safe place
it's where I can go and literally this
is my soul like here's my soul
[Music]
enjoy